[Applause]
they came in their thousands
pies demanding greater democracy
a united resistance all calling for
change
we need the real democracy and not just
a dictatorship
i just want a better leader for this
country
we want a new constitution that is
really democratic and we want that to
lead
to a democratic election and we want a
democratically
elected prime minister these
demonstrations have been steadily
growing in numbers over the last month
most anti-government but a smaller
number
calling for reform of the monarchy among
the bangkok crowd are protest leader out
on bale
one of three recently arrested and
charged with sedition
how worried are you let them let them do
the worst i am willing to sacrifice
anything for democracy
the prime minister the retired general
that previously led a military coup
has said the protesters views will be
listened to
but warned against dragging the palace
into the debate
you can't underestimate how radical and
potentially
dangerous it is that people here have
begun to openly discuss the role of the
monarchy
where criticism of the monarchy can end
in a 15 year jail sentence
while peaceful what is happening here is
unprecedented
a call for change which challenges
thailand's most
powerful institutions siobhan robbins
sky news bangkok